звідси до Румунії рукою подати але
більшість українських чоловіків не
можуть перейти Цей кордон принаймні
законно через воєнний стан чоловіки
призувного віку повинні залишатися в
країні підроблені документи Один із
способів порушити цю заборону ще один
шлях через густі ліси та гірські
перевали понад 15 000 людей було
затримано в Україні під час спроби
нелегально потрапити до Румунії
ці прикордонники намагаються їх зупинити
сьогодні вечері Володимир та Василь
відповідають за охорону 12тикілометрової
смуги щоб забезпечити дотримання закону
І можливо врятувати чиєсть життя тут
рівнина болотиста місцевість можуть і
заблудити дійсно так і може бути дикі
звірі Медвідь проживає у нас можуть
попасти на
медведя Нам повідомили що спочатку
повномасштабного російського вторгнення
у південному прикордонному регіоні
України було виявлено два десятки тіл
раніше цей маршрут був популярним серед
контрабандистів сигарет але зараз ним
переважно користуються люди які
намагаються залишити країну
ухилянти бженці
контрабандисти військовий стан бояться
що ми як їх затримуємо зразу їх
передаємо
оформляєм 204 штрафує після суду їх і
таки забирають вінкомат 204 стаття
передбачає адміністративний штраф за
незаконний перетин кордону до 8500 грн
за спробу виїзду з підробними
документами штраф або позбавлення волі
покарання у вигляді поїздки у військомат
не передбачено законом але може бути
негласною домовленістю військових і
прикордонників а далі перспектива що
лякає багатьох опинитися на фронті адже
Україні потрібні солдати у Чернівцях
неподалік румунського кордону їх
намагаються мотивувати ось такими
оголошеннями на початку війни сотні
тисяч людей пішли служити добровільно
через півтора року багато хто з них
виснажений поранений або загинув
більшість українців підтримують і
довіряють ЗСУ але служити готові не всі
згідно із соцопитуванням проведеним
улітку цьогоріч найперші ознаки
патріотизму на думку українців донати і
волонтерство а також спілкування
українською служба в армії на третьому
місці на військову службу можуть бути
призвані чоловіки віком від 18 до 60
років але є винятки наприклад батьки
трьох і більше дітей опікунихво батьків
незамінні працівники підприємств А ще
звільнення від служби за медичними
довідками Саме так більшість людей
Ухиляється від призову тисячі чоловіків
змогли виїхати за кордон підкупивши
чиновників злочинні групи що заробляють
на цьому рекламують свої послуги в
Telegram наприклад оформлення
інвалідності може коштувати до 35сяч
доларів це можливо лише за допомогою
чиновників і співробітників військоматів
у серпні було звільнено керівників усіх
обласних ТЦК У рамках більш масштабних
заходів що що до боротьби з корупцією в
оборонному секторі ну Щоби сказати що це
була тотальна корупція ми такого не
можемо сказати це радше були такі
поодинокі випадки ми просто відразу
кажемо що в нас Нульова толерантність до
випадків корупції чи інших порушень Так
звісно є людський фактор але ми
намагаємося реагувати на будь-які
проблеми але деякі українські чоловіки
замислюються Чому вони мають служити і
шукають способи уникнути призову
Максим один із них 22річний майстер тату
каже що підтримує ЗСУ але сам не хоче
воювати м кажется то что встаки соб Я
вважаю що власне країна це цінніше ніж
бути біженцем десь но
ціна але ціна яку просять заплатити за
власну країну каліцтво чи смерть для
мене набагато вища ніж ця
цінність Я краще став би біженцем аніж
помру але не факт що тут буде країна
Після того як ти помрешс того питаємо
Максима як він ставиться до
співвітчизників українців які змушені
жити під російською окупацією і
сподіваються на
визволеннясиму максимум за кого я пішов
би воювати - це моє близьке оточення ті
люди яких я вважаю своєю спільнотою люди
наприклад з Луганська я не сказав би що
це моя спільнота я їх не знаю і ніколи
не бачив і вони мене не знають і ніколи
не бачили насправді Для мене вони не
існують і я Для них не існую це дуже
дивна ідея воювати за людей котрих я
навіть ніколи не
бачив цих чоловіків нещодавно
мобілізували вони новобранці
Національної
гвардії серед них і Михайло вантажник у
цивільному житті він отримав повістку
чотири місяці тому я спочатку був
обмежено Ну так я і зараз обмежено
придати по стану здоров'я в мене От
немає і Ну я зрозумів що
взагалі-то Ну куда діватися ви бачите що
зараз на на кожному
кроці запрошують Скажем так Після
кількох тижнів тренувань Михайло як і
решта новобранців складає присягу
присягу ніколи не зрадити українському
народові чоловік не береться засуджувати
тих хто Ухиляється від служби але їхню
позицію не поділяє Я розумію що зараз я
не не в такому стані що можу одразу піти
Там на ву або ще щось Але ми всі по по
мірі своїх можливостей повинні нести
якусь
службу навіть у тилових частинах
потрібні
якісь працівники І я Я усім раджу Ну не
ховатися не тікати і не цей вас зразу
там не не не будуть цей ви
пройдете перевірку і тому подібне ну от
Навіть як я зараз обмежено придатний
мені мені знайдеться робота тут на
кордоні з Румунією Володимир та Василь
поки не виявили слідів незаконних
переходів Утім лише напередодні нашої
зйомки на цій ділянці кордону затримали
трьох чоловіків призовного віку які
намагалися перелізти через колючий дрід
по оперативній інформації наших
оперативних працівників які надали
інформацію те що особа яка проживає в
цій області е намагається скажемо так їх
переводити Ми цю особу скажемо так
визначили і попередньо швидше ніж вони
дійшли до місця де вони хотіли вчинити
правопорушення намагалися притнути
державний кордон незаконно
використовуючи певні для цього приладдя
стосовно якихось саморобних дерев'яних
типу
як ступеньк щось з того і вони просто їх
накидають на От цю от лінію інженер
споруд і завдяки ній отак от ї можуть
перейти тільки в серпні прикордонники
запобігли
2м47 випадкам перетину кордону насправді
ж їх набагато більше кожен має свое
мнение Я сам був воював знаю що там не
бажаю нікому там бути там нелегко Кока
судьба кажда людина свої приймає
[музика]
рішення вомир каже що не може судити тих
хто тікає Але як і сотні тисяч українців
що воюють на фронті прикордонники теж
мають обов'язок і вони сповнені
рішучості його
виконувати